par ici tous droits
un camion papa s'il te plaît dis moi que
tu as pas mis tout notre argent là
dedans l'inquiète il a mis mon argent
150 dollars pour être ici il avance sur
ton salaire mensuel
quel salaire mensuel sur lui que tu vas
reprendre quand jamais on n'a plus une
thune
je le savais trésor tu veux bien éviter
de casser les liens entre employeurs et
employés je croyais qu'on était associé
je suis un peu à ça etc ok je suis payé
sa robe de bal tu me vois lui repoussé
sa robe de bal
il a refusé le cavalier pourquoi pas la
robe faux j'ai proposé d'y aller d'être
son chaperon un père avec sa fille au
bal de fin d'année c'est space
la question n'est pas là justement
peut-être qu'elle devrait mon ange tons
chauds il raccourcit à vue d'oeil
tentant à l'eau froide et surtout pas de
sèche-linge